We've discussed everything you need to
know about creating notifications and
apps for Android Wear.
But one thing we haven't
discussed until now,
is how to show the time to the user.
Well, watch faces are such
an important feature of Android Wear
that we have a whole
lesson dedicated to it.
What's an Android Wear watch face?
A watch face is what's shown
when the screen is on, and
no other apps are running.
It's what you'll spend
the most time looking at.
And the first thing that others will
see, when they glance at your watch.
It's visible all the time, so you can
discreetly glance at the watch face,
without touching or
activating the device.
it goes without saying that
a watch face should show the time.
Watch faces can also be a highly
functional way to share concise,
timely information.
For example, a watch face can show
your next upcoming calendar event, or
the weather, or
the current price of a stock.
Watch faces are also
a personal statement of style.
We like to say that Android Wear
let's you wear what you want, and
no where is that more
true than a watch face.
The design guidelines we discussed for
wear are a framework on which to build
your creations, giving you room and
support for creative expression and
artistic freedom.